[Musik]
also die größte überraschung ist auf
jeden fall später sind ich glaube den
hatte keiner auf der rechnung
der als freiburger stürmer gar nicht so
im fokus steht im europapokal und jetzt
eben das erste mal überhaupt bei der
nationalmannschaft dabei ist bekannt aus
dem olympia da war schon dabei und hat
halt im finale den entscheidenen
elfmeter verschossen aber den hätte
wirklich keiner auf der rechnung und ich
muss sagen die entscheidung von löw
finde ich mutig aber mache habe ich auch
gesagt ich bin der meinung dass wir
hatten dieses jahr auch natürlich
gesehen und es war nicht unbedingt seine
saison wo er seine seine form die er
normalerweise bringen kann
mit seiner qualität eben auch so gezeigt
hat in dieser saison ist mario dazu zu
hause zu lassen bis so hart es klingt
richtig die alles was er 2014 geleistet
hat für die nationalmannschaft und auch
eben im finale kann vier jahre später
so hart es klingt nicht erzählen weil er
einfach nicht in der form ist im moment
das risiko manuel neuer jetzt in den
vorläufigen kader zu nominieren ist
gering weil er nun vier torhüter
nominiert hat das heißt am ende müssen
es drei sein ob manuel neuer dabei sein
wird wird man in zweieinhalb wochen
wissen wenn das trainingslager vorbei
ist und die endgültige frist für die
fifa abgelaufen ist dann muss man sehen
ob manuel neuer fit ist das wird sich
jetzt im trainingslager zeigen wenn ich
wüsste ob deutschland wieder weltmeister
ist weil ich reich ich glaube sie haben
gute chancen auf jeden fall wieder das
halbfinale zu erreichen
das gibt eigentlich die qualität der
mannschaft wieder her und danach ist es
auf diesem niveau so schwierig zu
offizieren dass wir uns einfach nicht
weiß es kommt auf die tagesform an das
kommt auch verletzt an
es kommt auch die taktik an
das sind sachen die man jetzt vorher
noch nicht sagen kann dann hätte auch
bei der em gedacht dass sie die beste
mannschaft sind hatten dann im
halbfinale sind ausgeschieden und von
daher kann man das nicht prognostizieren
aber aufs halbfinale würde ich